héguy main on attend évidemment la
conférence de presse emmanuel macron qui
devrait intervenir prochainement mais un
communiqué avant cela vient de tomber ce
matin
et oui tout à fait grégory un communiqué
disant que les partenaires européen et
canadien souhaite rester au sel et les
canadiens également les canadiens qui
souhaitent rester au sel pardon et que
les partenaires internationaux au sel
veulent étendre leur soutien aux pays du
golfe de guinée on attend bien entendu
des précisions quant au départ des
forces françaises du mali au
redéploiement dans la région en tout cas
il ne devrait pas y avoir beaucoup de
surprises quant à ce départ je vous le
rappelle cela fait des mois que les
relations se tendent entre paris et
bamako en fait depuis le coup d'état du
18 août 2020 les rapports avec le nouvel
homme fort du pays le colonel le colonel
à 6 me colleter à son compliqué tout
tout comme avec le premier ministre
chaubell maïga qui multiplie les
déclarations chocs le sentiment anti
français se développe au mali on a pu le
voir sur les images des manifestations
de ces dernières semaines le pouvoir
malien accusent paris de vouloir diviser
le pays et je vous le rappelle
l'ambassadeur français au mali avait été
sommé de plier bagage fin janvier
dernier bref à la france est gentiment
poussé vers la sortie je vous propose
d'écouter ce qu'on disait l'exécutif
hier
le statu quo n'est pas possible dans un
contexte très dégradé au mali avec la
prise de pouvoir par une junte le refus
d'appliquer un calendrier de retour à
l'ordre démocratique qui avait pourtant
été annoncée et le recours à une milice
privée russe
ce n'est pas un sujet franco malien nous
avons européaniser notre présence au
sahel avec l'appui d'une dizaine de pays
européens qui sont venus nous rejoindre
c'est dans ce travail de concertation
avec tous ses partenaires que les
décisions doivent être prises
à grimentz retrait concerne qui combien
d'hommes et surtout que deviendra la
présence militaire française au sahel
alors grégory très exactement cela va
concerner environ
2400 zone de la force barkan
principalement poster de dans le centre
et l'est du mali à gao gossip et ménaka
paris avait déjà transféré aux maliens
en fin d'année dernière les bases du
nord du pays alors il est fort probable
qu'une partie de ses effectifs soit
redirigée sur la base de niamey au niger
c'est l'une des plus importantes bases
françaises dans la région sahélo
saharienne avec celle de n'djamena au
tchad mais surtout elle a le mérite de
rester tout proche de la région d de la
région du liptako gourma aux régions
dites des trois frontières c'est celle
qui s'étend sur le sud ouest du niger le
centre et est du mali et dans le nord du
burkina faso c'est une zone cette zone
des trois frontières qui concentre une
une partie de la lutte contre les
djihadistes luttes menées vous l'avais
répété par la france depuis plus de huit
années maintenant quant à tabou baldeck
takouba pardon elle devrait logiquement
aussi quitté le mali puisqu'elle est
intégré à l'opération aube arcanes de
toute façon bamako a déjà demandé au
danemark de retirer la centaine d'hommes
posté dans le pays et la suède a
également annoncé le départ de ces 150
militaires alors on ne sait pas trop où
ira précisément à tout ce beau monde les
pays voisins serait intéressé pour
récupérer une partie de la présence de
des forces de barkan et à kouba je vous
le rappelle 4800 militaires français
sont présents au sel et avait que 40
aéronefs et 780 véhicule alors ça peut
paraître beaucoup comme cela mais je
vous rappelle que la zone à couvrir est
immense comparable à la surface de
l'europe on ne s'en rend pas forcément
compte 1 sur une projection mercator
mais il y a plus de distance entre
nouakchott sur la côte mauritanienne
jusqu'à la frontière orientale du tchad
contre lisbonne et moscou de vastes
étendues donc un qu'il est difficile de
sécuriser avec finalement si peu
d'hommes d'autant que la france est
aussi présente ailleurs sur les côtes
ouest africaines du sénégal au gabon et
on ajoute à cela on vient de l'apprendre
je voulais rappeler tout à l'heure en
plus la présence qui va s'étendre
maintenant sur les pays du golfe de
guinée
merci guimard aussi pour toutes ces
précisions merci également à frédéric ch
qui vous accompagnent derrière la caméra